First question is, how old do I have to be to join Emirates?
Minimum age for Emirates is 21 years of age.
Do I need a diploma or a degree for Emirates?
The answer to that is no.
You need proof of finishing or completing secondary school.
I think that's all that you need.
When you're applying online, you tell them which city you would like to interview at.
If you're in a situation where you just can't make it...
...to the location that they set you on on that date,...
..just write to them and they will offer you something else.
You should treat your interview as any other job application...
...because it's exactly the same.
They are going to ask you about your previous working experience, what job role you had,...
...what challenges you had in that job,...
...and you won't get asked any of those questions until your final interview stage.
If you're invited to a final interview, that's when they're gonna be asking these questions.
Up until that stage, it's just group activity.
What are the Emirates looking for in a cabin crew?
Firstly, you should always be polite.
Now, that should go without saying but you should always treat the recruiters...
...and your possibly future colleagues with respect and be polite.
The second thing I always say is to smile.
You always need to smile.
Always have inner confidence, so that on your open day,...
...you can give everyone the impression that, "Yes, I am meant to be here..."
"...and this job is meant for me."
"I am meant for the job and I want this job."
Politeness, always smile, quietly confident: that's the three things I'd say that...
...they are looking for and that you should be on your open day.